let's end is nice ember with their
latest Disney film saving mr. banks this
one is definitely we're talking about
because this is the first Disney film
that's actually about the making of a
Disney film and that's something like
The Reluctant dragon where you have
these fictional characters going through
and seeing how stuff is animated I mean
like the real process
I mean Walt Disney talking about
developing an idea and trying to work
with the author to come to a compromise
and creative decisions and choices and
disagreements for Disney this is really
new territory for a film to take the
film stars Emma Thompson as P L Travers
she's the author of Mary Poppins and is
incredibly resistant to handing over the
rights to Disney to make a movie out of
it why because a lot of it came from her
true life experiences on the farm she
had a father she really loved who was an
alcoholic and a nanny / aunt who came in
to make everything better but when the
Disney Corporation wants to for lack of
a better word Disney fie it she wants no
part of it and keeps saying that if they
want the rights they had to play by her
rules and the rest of the movie is them
trying to figure out how to make this
film work Disney wants it one way she
wants it another
it's the Battle of the egos going back
and forth back and forth
Disney being the charming businessman
and Travers the brutal purist who wants
to see her vision exactly how she
imagined it one of the great things
about this film is that it's done almost
entirely from the developmental point of
view you don't really see the set or
lighting or cameras actors anything like
that it's all from the development of
the sketches the song the ideas and so
forth you don't usually see that that
often Emma Thompson is wonderful as P L
Travers but the one that really shocked
me was Tom Hanks as Disney when I saw
him in this role I rolled my eyes and
said oh god this is gonna bomb there is
no way this is gonna work but within
five minutes he really won me over he
captured the charming businessman but he
also got sort of that element of he
always gets what he wants he'll
compromise but in the end he still wants
it a certain way and he's gonna get it
when I think back to the movie I don't
imagine seeing Hanks there I actually
imagine the real Disney sitting there
talking with her
that's pretty damn impressive the movie
even shows some elements that I don't
think Disney years ago would ever allow
for example you see Walt smoke drink and
swear it's not for very long but it's in
there you even see him kind of be back
stamping like when he doesn't invite P L
Travers to the premiere this is a side
of Disney that I'm really checked the
studio is allowing but I'm really glad
they are it shows they're comfortable
with their honesty but I think they also
realize the importance that this also
makes it more relatable and identifiable
all the other actors are wonderful on
recreating these roles the Sherman
Brothers the driver they're all
fantastic and are given a lot to work
with there's only two problems I have
with the movie one is that the
flashbacks while well done seem like two
totally different movies a lot of times
her memories are a little too whimsical
but you could argue that sort of a
romanticized version of it they do make
it clear that these are her memories
that's how she saw it so you can
technically give it a pass but the two
don't always gel together I'm also kind
of bothered about the ending without
giving too much away they show her at
the premiere and her reaction to it
anyone that knows the real story knows
what P L Travers really thought about
the movie and in this film you can make
a very slim argument that maybe that's
what they're hinting yet but no majority
of the audiences would watch this and
think that she's reacting to it a
certain positive way I think he'd be
very difficult to find an audience
member to see this film and think oh
yeah that properly represented what she
thought of her creation being brought to
the big screen and while those two
elements do bother me I'm still really
impressed with how incredibly adult this
movie is remember how I was talking
about 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea and
how even though it was a family movie it
was written in a very adult way and how
Disney films don't really do that
anymore this film does this takes it
very seriously and doesn't do that much
for a little kid it's mainly at adults
like I said the flashback can be a
little too whimsical and there's even a
scene where apparently she's dancing
with the Sherman Brothers - lets go fly
a kite and yeah
it's a touch to Disney ish but those
moments are very rare and even then
they're not awful they just seem a touch
out of place I was really impressed with
it and glad that they chose such an
adult angle to tackle it with this could
have very easily been made to corny or
to Disney fied but they found a really
good balance and use some real sincere
honesty to it that I think is very
welcome and in my opinion I think it
really shows the evolution of Disney as
has all of Disney cember there's a
wonderful scene where Disney talks about
how he actually understands what Travers
is going through and talks about when he
was offered a bunch of money for Mickey
they said even though he had no money at
the time he could never sell them
because as he puts it that mouse's
family and it may respects that's what
Disney has become family yeah there's a
lot of things you don't agree with and
you're not always gonna enjoy them but
they were there from the beginning
they'll be there at the end
Disney hasn't really gotten any better
or worse it's just sort of changed it's
evolved with time and nose that has to
be a little different in order to
survive but what those different changes
comes all sorts of unique visions
wonderful characters and new ways of
looking at stories both old and it's
been really great going through all
these Disney films through December and
keep an eye out in January I might still
do one or two by popular demand that a
lot of people are complaining I should
oops but through this month I've loved
seeing Disney Vault change and turn into
something that is definitely different
but still so familiar I love them so
many years ago I know I love them so
many years in the future thanks for
watching and be sure to still keep that
mouse
you